how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
you don't have to know anything about
Dungeons and Dragons to get into this
story
of the characters are a group of
pedifies
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
I mean the least the greatest evil the
world has ever known but we're gonna fix
it
I'm a con man I team up with Safina of
the dreaded red wizard red Wizards
created an army of the undead to conquer
the nation
such immense evil and they look so
incredibly powerful you know not the
scope of my back
that's an amazing thing to have these
Bandits coming together trying to save
the world it's pretty badass
it's a hero's journey of good against
evil this ends now whatever happens
we'll be ready
thank you